so Trevor I keep hearing all about this
machine learning stuff but a lot of it
goes over my head I used to think that
too but it turns out you can get started
with it pretty easily in fact I was able
to build the machine learning model in
just a few minutes and all you needed
was a highly trained data scientist
right nope just some data in bakery here
let me show you how
let's get started the first step in any
email problem is gathering data so I'm
going to use publicly available data on
city bike share usage and weather in
Austin Texas I'm going to try and
predict how the weather in Austin
affects the daily trips per bike which
the city could use to make decisions
about pricing of insurance for those
bikes or how many bikes to leave out on
a rainy day I start in the bigquery web
console and use the create model command
to name and train my model I specify
that this is a linear regression model
and then my input column are the value
that I'm going to be predicting is trips
per bike next I use standard sequel to
choose the feature columns or model
inputs that are going to be used to
predict trips for bike in this case
temperature and precipitation data
I then train my model which will all
happen in just about 30 seconds while
the model is training let's get our
model ready to be evaluated this is how
you will find out important stats about
your model like how useful it is for
predictions and what your average error
is once the model is trained you can
click the model in your BQ data set
which will include information on the
training stats like the number of
iterations your model ran and what your
training loss was and your learn rate to
evaluate our model we run the ML
evaluate command referencing the name of
the model we want to evaluate then
selecting the same feature columns we
use to train our model in our first
query two columns to pay close attention
to our r-squared score and mean squared
error you typically want an r-squared
score closer to one so there's a lot of
room for improvement in this model
there's a great article in the
description that talks more about how to
interpret the results of your model but
let's go ahead and use our model to make
a prediction the predict command is
almost identical to our ml evaluate
command except we are going to select a
new column for our predicted values at
the beginning of the query and specify
the ml predict command and voila we have
some predictions so there's still a lot
that I don't quite get but I feel like I
could start using this today the deep
test can be pretty complicated but this
is a great way to get started making
predictions and learning more don't
forget to Like comment and subscribe for
more great Google cloud platform content
[Music]